oh
i don't really think it's the right time
to lift the mandate
i understand that she's keeping it
inside of the schools but i think even
though that is up indoors area we should
keep it for other indoor areas as well
we're keeping the children safe they're
cross-referencing with the adults we
should keep everyone safe for now it's
not going to affect the way that i
approach things throughout the pandemic
i have thought that wearing a mask has
been easy
useful for me and useful for the people
around me so i intend to continue
to wear a mask when i enter a restaurant
i'll probably wear a mask when i attend
the theater or in a movie theater
in my office i probably will no longer
wear a mask walking down the corridor to
the men's room or the cafeteria but
other than that i'm going to continue to
be masked i think it needs to be
carefully done and and monitored as we
try to get back to life but
in spaces like theater and large events
i think it should still be there i don't
think it needs to go away there's
nothing that
needs to make us feel like we shouldn't
wear it we're not out of the woods yet i
feel as if it's okay i mean people are
vaccinated and there's you know immunity
somewhat at this point so i think as
long as we're outside i think that's
fine you know not to wear a mask but i
think if you're indoors you should keep
wearing your mask
everybody should get vaccinated and
boosted and we'll be done with it
actually i have noticed that there's
been more compliance in new york than
what i have seen in the southeast and i
feel that there is a better
usage of vaccinations here and
testing so i think she's making a safe
decision of course i will wear my mask
i'm a senior citizen but
i have no problem with it
i don't think that's very safe right now
yeah
with corona still being on the rise and
still being as deadly as it is i don't
think that's safe to do